I met for president last night  Donald Trump gave me a fright  he said I'm kind of a dick he's right  I'm tired of faking I'm tired of right  it's wrongly  inkay  [Music]  just cuz I start  oh my citizens  I think it's gonna be a run wrong time  to Donald Trump begins to refine I'm not  a tear and that he thinks I am Oh No  [Music]  rocket  [Music]  Rocketman  you know  irony so much Donald  [Music]  we've turned the tables on Al Gore and  use the internet to our advantage if you  liked this video subscribe by hitting  the subscribe button or the notification  bell next to it because subscribing  isn't enough watch one of these other  videos and you know listen you can you  can stick around you don't have to but  here's the thing the fact that you're  still listening to me saying stick  around as I say stick around and you're  sticking around the BAA we just added  another add you just made me for more  sense